So, here's a, a very simple outermost state chart in which we
have an unplugged state and a plugged-in state. The pulling the plug causes us
to go from the plugged-in state to the unplugged state. And I've labeled here,
this is not part of the state chart notation, but
I've labeled here, what the event number is in our table.
So vent number five is the pulling of the plug. Symmetrically, the,
going from the unplugged to the plugged-in state is plugging in the plug, and
that's, that's event number six, okay? But for the remainder of the,
this exercise, we're only going to, consider sub states of the plugged-in state.
That is, now, imagine that, the rightmost state here has all of those other
concurrently executing machines which we were, talking about previously.